all right welcome back to the show
everybody we're gonna do calls today but
we're doing them a different way because
of all of the complaints about the call
quality on
the phone line we are going to for the
first time
try taking callers through discord which
is davidpakman.com discord so let's just
try it
okay we're going to go first uh to
rachel from
arizona rachel from arizona you're the
first caller on today
uh in terms of using the new discord
system
welcome can you hear me can we hear you
i can hear you can you hear me rachel
you're coming through
crystal clear how are you today
good good what's uh what's on your mind
well
well after that dumpster fire of a
debate last night
i mean i just
i don't think there was a clear winner
on either side
so i mean listen i i agree with you that
it was a mess and trump's strategy was
to make debate impossible
i do think that on balance like it's
hard for me to say because i'm in this
like i'm not the target of this debate
you know i'm voting for biden and it's
i'm very clear on that but i think the
big picture is
biden looked stable and trump didn't and
i think that
if we imagine a casual political
observer
sure people who want like an alpha type
that insults everybody they might be
drawn to trump but i think
it probably is better for biden how it
went right
i agree with you on that 100 i mean
compared to trump biden just looked like
a saint right compared to him just
you know his hot-headedness and
and it was it was definitely
um not the norm for a presidential
debate now let me ask you this rachel as
someone who follows politics
do you based on how that debate went do
you feel any need to watch future
debates or are you sort of like good for
the rest of this election
um i just want to watch it for the pure
uh you know what's the word
the entertainment values like a train
yeah the entertainment it's like a train
wreck you just can't look away
yeah yeah yeah yeah see i think that
it's hard for us to analyze it because
i'm trying to think of people who are
watching it to try to figure out who to
vote for how are they seeing it and
might
we'll have to see in the coming days how
the polling shifts but my instinct is it
did
more damage for trump than it did for
biden
right and i am i'm originally from ohio
and so i have a lot of people on my
facebook and instagram from ohio
yeah and i was kind of interested to see
their take on it because a lot of them
are for trump
right and um you know they're just
making excuses for him oh
you know he he got the hardest questions
and
oh that's interesting because so because
one reaction would be to insist that
trump did great and he won but what
you're seeing
is people aren't saying trump did great
and he won but they're excusing the fact
that he imploded by saying he was
he got the hard questions and whatnot
correct that's
interesting that's different i mean i
think that signals it was worse for
trump
because they're not even able to just
claim he won they're having to make
excuses for the performance that
actually is interesting
right well i mean that's all they've
done for the past four years isn't it
excuses for him very true very true
rachel thank you for the call where in
arizona are you
i am in tempe tempe okay i've never been
there i've been to tucson i've been to
phoenix i've been to some wineries down
uh closer to the i think sonoida near
the mexican border beautiful
beautiful place yes it's very gorgeous
especially right now it's like just a
little above 100 still
and it's just perfect weather but it's a
dry heat so it's fine
yes yes that's what they all say all
right thank you so much for having me on
appreciate it i love your show thanks
rachel
great to hear from rachel i want to take
a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors s h masks
snh masks has everything you need when
it comes to
face masks and other protective gear for
covid19 and they're giving my audience
20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five-layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks
and shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david